das nächste monument humba humba humba
humba humba humba humba normal wie
produktiv sind
hallo ich ihn freuen und herzlich
willkommen zur capt minecraft 212 und in
der letzten folge war ca sowie die folge
in kempten kreft 1 mit dem gas für dich
sagen und ihr habt ein bisschen spaß da
sogar oma oder mit 1000 monster nicht
nur mit einem wie mit dem gas damit 1000
das war echt die letzte folge das
fahrrad war damals beschrieben hast mit
einem wort einfach nur explosionen ich
hab die folge mit dem wort explosionen
geschrieben und das war leichter ist das
passende wort hast du noch irgendwas
goldenes für mich oder irgendwie
coloration ist habe ich aber in der
truhe gerade gelegt warte mal rockig das
reingelegt ja es ist die erste studie
über allrad gollia ich hab schon das
gold aber wir brauchen noch jemand zum
brennen
ja wir haben kohle doch je hattest du
und bestraft
wir haben schon fünf dollar ecke das
wäre peinlich wenn ich die komplette
kohle da warten was mal 3 wir schaffen
dieser folge den dodge apple immer
schaffen wir in deinen folgen die aktiv
mit sowas nie war es so krass spannend
das war echt so unnormal wir waren da
unten und die haben derzeit gleich
nochmal oder hatte aber die letzte folge
das war echt so unnormal
ihr braucht zum verbrennt mit im rahmen
der baum ist ein echter schritt unfällen
und 9
mach ich super
die krone ist noch abblocken obwohl doch
wer jetzt noch einen neuen oder oder wie
war das
ich habe einen die kiste da glaube ich
gelegt hat block oder habe ich in dieser
kiste gibt ja hier ist schon da ist etwa
die wertvollen kiste ja er dachte ich
mir so aus intuition um erde ist
wertvoll aber diesem projekt alles
anders brauchen wir noch ein apfel wenn
jetzt noch ein apfel hätten aber er
kommt ja wahrscheinlich aus dem baum und
wir haben auch ein apfel ortschaft
metzingen chapel in dieser folge ich
schaue mir noch ein bisschen hier bei
diesen du dich eigentlich schon immer
gefreut hast ich glaube das war fast die
ganze zeit schon immer geredet hast nur
darüber immer deutsch apple natürlich
spargel und was man auch sagen muss wir
haben eine rose leider verloren da war
eine rose und mit der hätten wir mit
rosen und bauen will hat man sich
irgendwie pink machen können und hier
warte hier steht hat ihr ist lang da ist
braun
dafür konnte cacau und hier ist pink das
hätten wir da dann hinstellen können
müssen wir mal schauen hier screen dafür
brauchen wir kakteen da ist weiß weist
das war einmal
moment ich hab da mal eine kleine idee
etwas was ich mal ganz kurz austesten
möchte
ok reagiert nicht das video dann weiß er
was für'n weiß nie wie eine weiße
farbstoff guck mal bitte ganz kurz in
der wik events eben möglich ist
weißer farbstoff ich habe jetzt gedacht
mit bauen will aber das ging gerade
nicht weil wir haben acht gebranntem ton
farbstoff nach tun haben wir brannten
ton
da ist der gebrannte tun mit knochen
will ja dann bräuchten wir noch
irgendwie heizmaterial
ja ich nehme einfach die stöcke ebenso
dann kann ich nämlich ich weiß wie wir
eine rote rose wir bekommen jedoch nicht
weil wir auf erde ja aber wir haben
keine erde
ja wir können ja wir haben wenn es
hochkommt vier erde ach wir haben kein
grab das meinst du das meine ich genau
stimmt wenn kein gras aber wer hält und
in albany der gras blog vielleicht haben
wir in einer kiste das war super
allerdings komme ja ich habe acht weiß
gefärbten ton und ich bin bereit diesen
anzuwenden
nein leider nicht warte noch warte noch
ruhig mal ruhig und meine lieben freunde
wir schaffen das nächste monument und
wären damit ein ich sag's noch nicht
mehr so hoch zwei bühnen schein kämpfte
weiter sich hühner jetzt haben wir sie
wieder okay wir machen ein gehege für
die hühner jetzt schicken bätscher ja
heute ein tolles bild auf twitter nennen
welches ich habe es nicht gesehen also
ich war noch bassist retweetet auch von
dir ja ja das stimmt also da hat kann
ihn sich nicht lumpen lassen sich mal
wieder gesagt ja ich war richtigen witz
raus schreibe ich auch einfach mal ein
bommel da was du geschrieben am flirten
oder als kalorienbombe klärt sich ein
heißes kick in einem heißen wagen dass
es da wo komme dieses hühnchen dabei
zugeschaut hat wo es in dem in dem
fahrzeug saß als leiter alter alter
alter ich kann mir den neuen apple
machen nehmen wir möchte ich aber ich
habe eine ganz andere sache gerade ja
was dann ich warte gerade hier oben bei
den beim bauen denn den baum habe ich
gefällt ganz normal
und hier sind noch drei blätter und ich
habe auch kein setzlinge halten so
wartet bevor ich jetzt diesen laut apple
mache schaue ich noch mal ganz kurz nach
ob das ich hab's not einsetzt licht
gehen jetzt nicht erhalte aus den drei
blätter sind wir richtig gas haben wir
kein baum mehr
alter bitte bitte bitte was ist denn los
apple der mit dem gold blöcken okay ich
mache jetzt einfach mal humba humba
humba humba humba humba humba und ich
hole aufhob oracles aber geraten mir
naja jetzt geht es ja mal schauen was
ich jetzt offenbart hat vielleicht das
und wieder eine weitere kiste
hier ist erstmal noch blau blau bleibt
es laut schlie vielleicht haben ihn in
der höhle irgendwann lapislazuli das
kann ja sein aber nicht irgendwie noch
tot da das symptom mache ich mal ganz
kurz noch mal hier
15 toten die kann ich dann auch gleich
wieder brennen weil die farbe kommt noch
etwas hinzu karower an
da war doch in dem eingang ein stück
zuckerrohr oder und da kommen wir jetzt
ran
da brauchen wir noch ein echtes nicht
glaube schon aber gold müssen wir auf
jeden fall nicht mehr auch nach ausschau
halten erhöht
pak den goldenen apfel man nicht in
erstens geht nicht dass wir außerdem
noch essen oder so so ich warte immer
noch hier auf den samen vom baum zwei
blätter sind wir noch älter
es kann nicht deren ernst sein dass ein
baum einfach mal in kleinen setzling wir
tropft ich habe übrigens auch fackeln
für dich okay
jedes mal wieder erwarte hier jetzt
gehen wir sehr verschwenderisch mit
einem polster
guck mal hier
die beiden blätter alter nein da muss
zusätzlich rauskommen dass eine neue
kiste gleich noch eine schiefe dann
kommt eine neue kiste bier und hier auch
nur noch ein archiv mit
und das steht weiter bei den erfolgen
hatte den doppel haben wir jetzt also
danach kommen doch gar nichts mehr
das skelett ja soll ich noch meine kuh
töten
mario handy-flat er dann leder raus er
mache ich nur wer mit 23 humba humba
humba humba humba bricht die platte
heide druck setzt sich reif goalie ich
möchte auch sein 321 lapislazuli die
goldene karotten kürbiskuchen alte was
wir heute da der folge schaffen
richtig viel mein moment schon 2 ivm es
sei niemals teuren sterbe 5000 und die
gelbe blume die gelbe blume ok wir
können den nächsten monaten wohl ihr
wohl ihr wohl jawohl
und jetzt brauche ich eine rote truhe
eine rote blume
man man man na gut egal so was ich
packte gelbe man da rein dann kriegen
wir gelben farbstoff den gelben
farbstoff am rande ich jetzt mit dem
gebrannten ton der hier immer noch immer
brennt moment hatte hier ist noch weiß
gefärbt patronen euch den tonen gewartet
da habe ich auf jeden fall noch drohen
bekommen so sagt ihr tun
ich muss die in die brennende teile den
brennan habe ich nicht in dem material
hier kann ich nicht treffen nehmen die
brauchen wir wahrscheinlich eh nicht
ja funktionieren ok ich brauch drei
stück dann kann ich nämlich aus dem
gebannten torello machen
nun dann setze ich wir haben schon los
angeles
was kann man denn noch blumen noch
machen muss man das nicht mit irgendwas
fahren oder ständig hat jetzt ja
wirklich jeder hat sachen ausmacht aber
wir haben ja schon mal nachgeguckt
stimmt so viel was wir in einer folge
schaffen würden er da vielleicht zu viel
können gerne so viel schaffen wie wir
schaffen
ich habe das holz wir aufgesteckt von
dem baum dass auch ein blatt ich hoffe
eigentlich erwachsen wie ein paar
blätter darum ein grad kommt man so ist
es nun mal ganz gelesen
green wahrscheinlich nicht oder
vielleicht aufs grün grün kriegt man aus
blau und lila platz vier blöcken krieg
auf jeden fall ja ich liebe es okay okay
okay so komme die nicht produktiv ja
weil man sind krank humba humba humba
humba humba humba humba humba humba was
was hab ich gemacht wir haben scharfe
bekommen ja warum habe ich den erfolg
bekommen nachzucht hieß der
was heißt das ist der nachzucht als sie
nicht ich weiß was ich mache da du hast
vermehre zwei kühe mit weizen acht das
ging erst nach kuh schubser komme wie
produktiv sind wir denn das kann auch
nicht mehr sein
das kann nicht wahr sein alter wie
produktiv sind wir denn komme in der
folge heute
wir haben zwei monumente geschafft wir
haben zwei kisten geöffnet wir haben
drei erfolge geschafft unten ist jetzt
das zuckerrohr auch noch frei unten ist
auch wieder eine neue kiste frei
die folge ist noch nicht mal relativ
lang krass dass er oft lässt dennoch
normal
warte mal hast du noch zaun für die
schafe und christine fürst münchen
conrad moneygram kein holz weil das ding
ist wegen dem baum
was machten weder guck dir das mal an
ihr habt einfach aus holz wieder
aufgestellt dahinter die rede wo mein
gott was wir könnten vielleicht mal die
schafe in einen kleinen zaun machen
damit wir noch ein bisschen was
unproduktives machen wir wollen nein
eben nicht wenn im holz werden ja nicht
unendlich viel
wir haben kein baum mittlerweile haben
wir echt so fiel das nein überhaupt
nicht
wer jetzt angst dass er sterben im kein
baum mehr überlegt sie das mal aber ich
glaube da unten noch zäune
ich schaue mal ganz kurz einfach stimmt
wir am alter da muss doch das wird auf
keinen fall nach wachsen da muss ein
setzling rauskommen ok solches wäre
abfällen oder was ja en alte art
gegenstück zur produktivität in der
heutigen folge
nein eine man man man
ich habe eine kleine idee was wir machen
könnten
und die wäre achtlinge zeigen wie das
aufteilen lassen
eine kleinere einfach das finale das
denke ich brauche ja nicht so viel platz
stimme auch hier eigentlich nur zwei
davon will aber kein archiv mit mehr und
essen haben wir genug also laufen kann
man da eben von denen sei es theoretisch
reicht wir nur eine
aber ich will dass ihr alle da so das
heißt beim jetzt wird und jetzt kommt
hier kommen da die schafe platz haben
die die haben zwei platz kriegen die
schafhalter per setzling bekommen haben
einfach keinen bekommen alter was machen
wir jetzt
ein weißer hand nicht dass die den
nachlauf warte ich oder ich wohl eben
noch zäune ja darum können wir später
erst mal noch gedanken machen ein haben
wir ja noch vielleicht geht das ja auch
irgendwie anders mit dem pflanzen oder
so keine ahnung ich glaub ich hab 19 19
habe ich noch das heißt ich mache mir
eben hier noch so eine scheiße l
eigentlich darfst du dir auch nicht
kriegt man setzlingen wenn man die
kaputtheit ja eigentlich schon wie heavy
wie mainz das wenn mappus droht die
blätter blätter ja manchmal schon
manchmal nicht aber man kann auch
einfach warten macht keinen unterschied
ich habe jetzt den zaun tor gemacht
danach beenden wir dann auch mal die
folge so hohl die mannschaft mal hier
hin
ich bin hier gerade noch wir unten
nimmer weizen mit und goldenen san falls
welchen hast
ich habe auch nur zwei stücke weizen
also männlich ja das reicht auch du
musst ja nur anziehen quasi und sanya
dafür bin ich hier runter gegangen da
hab ich ihn so wie viel sind ist da
wovon vom sand 12 der ok es ist gebt mir
mal erst mal den sand und danach ziehe
die türen des geheges anderen endlich
seinen bald eine schwägerin hier war man
fast so ja mach hier auch noch die leute
eben zu person der jetzt ziehe die
schafe in das andere gehege da hinten
kommt und dann bei euch da nämlich das
sound hin wenn sie da sind
was in hand okay das andere auch noch
das andere noch
du bist du schon gelaufen jetzt
realisieren sie dich nicht mehr oder
wasser schubsen nein nein doch nicht
allein
peter weck das thema erstmal eine gruppe
stellen warteraum den ganzen anderen
jetzt stelle ich mich einfach hierhin
macht den hier schaut man was tier habe
die lieben dich zwar schon welche 22
reichen ja erst mal nein mach doch
wieder rein genau ob sie einfach das
machen sie denn da komm' raus und der
andere kommt auch noch ok ich weiß nicht
ob die dadurch passt machen besonderes
du kannst ja noch sparen das kleine
schar kleiner etwa nicht gedeckt bleibe
aber ich will sagen wir weiter der
nächsten folge
die kommt dann morgen bei ghom auf den
kanal und wir haben richtig viel
geschafft alter ich würde sagen dass ich
diese produktive folge gefallen dann
lassen sie uns mit einem mag ich wissen
und schaut morgen die folge bei kommen
und dann sehen wir uns dort morgen
wieder schön mit